is the iphone 13 mini really worth
buying in 2021
well today we will find out because
we're gonna compare it to all of these
different iphones including the lower
price iphone se last year's 12 and 12
mini and the 13 and 13 pro and with that
i have to say that this year apple has a
few secrets for the mini that you guys
have to know to make a really good
decision with that we are going to
compare the performance did apple slow
down this phone we're going to compare
the speakers which almost nobody does
and even the speeds of 5g to see if
apple fixed a major problem from before
and also talk about battery life screen
sizes and more let's get prices out of
the way along with what you absolutely
shouldn't buy at the base we have 400
bucks for the se and then at 600 bucks
we do have the 12 mini which i would not
buy you guys will see here in a little
bit as we do this comparison why i
wouldn't buy that and then for 700 you
can either buy a 13 mini or an iphone 12
i'll be talking about that and then of
course for 800 you can go for the 13 and
then a big jump of a thousand and 1100
for these larger phones now most of this
comparison if you're thinking about
buying one of these you're going to be
looking at these ones right here at the
lower end price now as far as design
differences all of these have the same
new boxy design other than the iphone se
let's go ahead and pull these in here
now i also have to point out that all
these less expensive phones they're all
product red and you guys can see the
color difference between them last year
i really didn't like the salmon colored
product red the se looked better but
this year's 13 mini looks gorgeous i
love that dark deep red color now as far
as those design differences between
these two phones you guys can see that
we have these flat sides on the 13 mini
and the rest of the 12 and 13 lineup
compared to the se which has the older
iphone 8 7 and 6 design with the rounded
edges so personally i really prefer the
look and feel of the new 12s and 13s you
have this nice flat sides that give you
a lot of grip compared to the rounded
sides and you guys can also see the size
difference between these two phones even
though the se has a smaller screen
overall it is larger and with that it is
actually wider in your hand as well so
if you're somebody that's coming from an
older iphone that uses this design of
the size the 13 mini is actually going
to be smaller and narrower for you which
does help as far as comfort and on the
front we have another major difference
as you guys could see without that home
button and that little forehead we have
a much larger display we have 5.4 inches
compared to 4.7 now you're probably
familiar with touch id iphones i've had
them for years of course that is gone
but instead we do have face id which for
the most part is a lot more convenient
it can automatically lock you into apps
without even having to move your finger
down there to authenticate now as far as
this plays i went ahead and adjusted
that top camera and you guys can see
that the 13 mini has another major
advantage and that is brightness it can
now reach 800 nits of brightness
compared to 625 on the 12s and the se
and that really helps when you're
outside in bright lighting or just in
bright environments now as far as
watching hdr video all the iphone 12s
and 13s are the same at 1200 nits but of
course the se cannot pull that off so
let's see how it compares you guys could
see there is a massive difference not
only in brightness where the iphone 13
swimming janet is popping like crazy but
also contrast because this is an oled
display like the rest of the 12s and the
13s you have those deep rich darks
instead of the lcd panel which for its
time was actually the best now it just
cannot compare with the bright and nice
and contrasty hdr oled display that's in
the iphone 13. now with that what i'm
really curious about is how do the
speakers compare on the 13 mini compared
to the 13 which is a larger size cost
100 bucks more and of course the older
generation phones like the se which has
the same speakers as the iphone 8 and
those are slightly better than the 7 and
the 6 so let's go ahead and compare them
[Music]
[Music]
all right wow that was a pretty big
difference between them you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section i'll start out with the se which
is the same as the eight and better than
the seven and six because it has an
earpiece speaker and the difference is
dramatic louder better bass better mids
and a huge thing is if you like to watch
videos with the se and the older phones
you're not really having a balanced
sound between the bottom speaker and the
left hand side one or the earpiece
speaker most of the sound comes from the
bottom whereas with the se it is really
balanced because apple has upgraded the
erp speaker with this new model it
sounds a lot better now with that said
other than having a little bit louder of
an earpiece speaker one very interesting
thing is that apple didn't really
upgrade the speakers compared to the 12
mini it sounds almost the same other
than slightly louder on the left hand
side
where they actually did make a really
big upgrade with the iphone 13 sounding
louder better in every way compared to
the 12 so don't expect much better sound
if you already have a 12 minute and you
want to upgrade to the 13 mini but from
an older phone the difference is really
dramatic with that said if you're trying
to decide between a 13 minute or a 13
and you care about sound quality the 13
is definitely much better better bass
more richer mids the highs are a little
bit more clear and it's a lot louder as
well and now for what i'm very
interested in if apple limited the
iphone 13 mini compared to the regular
13 and how that compares to the 12s now
right here we have geekbench five open
and starting out with the se this thing
has the a13 bionic with three gigs of
ram compared to the 12s which have the
a14 bionic with four gigs and of course
the 13s with that new a15 also four gigs
of ram now as far as ram i think four
gigabytes should be the standard i think
three is still a little bit small unless
all you do is maybe take some pictures
every once in a while and maybe make
phone calls but with that said let's go
ahead and start our cpu benchmark all
right we have a result and the 13 mini
is quite a bit faster than the se in the
multi-core it's a 50 faster and in
single core about 30 faster and along
with that extra gig of ram this thing is
gonna be much quicker and lasts you many
more years than if you spend the money
and buy the se now compared to the 12
mini and the 12 the 13 mini is 15 faster
in multi-core and about 9 faster in
single core which isn't really that big
of a difference so i really wouldn't
care about performance now as you guys
see the 13 and 13 mini the performance
is basically the same very small
differences even smaller than last year
so you're not really trading off any
performance if you're going with the
smaller phone and what's very
interesting is that if you compare it to
this phone the 13 pro with six gigs of
ram the results are still very similar
we have less of a difference this year
than we did last year with the 12
compared to the 12 pro so as far as
performance this is the smallest kind of
loss you get by going with the smaller
phone and the next two categories that
i'm going to cover are extremely
extremely important one of them that
you're probably suspecting the other one
that you're not let's start off with
that one with the iphone 12 mini not
only did people complain about the
battery life but i actually found that
the reception was much worse than the
iphone 12 and that caused me not to be
able to use it even though i really
liked it as you guys could see in this
download test with 5g i got a 124
megabit per second download compared to
197. that's close to half the speed not
only that in certain parts of the city i
literally did not get a signal with the
iphone 12 mini but i did with the
regular 12 and the 12 pros so that was a
deal breaker for me so what happens with
the 13 minute is it still limited with
suckier reception well i actually did a
speed test and as you guys could see we
got the same 201 actually slightly
faster than the 12 and an upload speed
of actually 34 whereas the old mini was
much lower and then comparing that to
the iphone 13 we got 203 here and a
slower download just for that test so
yes apple did fix the modem and the
antenna problem with the 13 mini
compared to the 12.
now i'll let you guys know why that is
in a second but if we open up the se if
you're thinking about upgrading from an
older iphone and an se the eight or the
seven you guys could see that without
the 5g with the lte we get a download to
be the 57 and that's not even super fast
5g that's just your normal slower 5g um
so you definitely are gonna get better
reception with the mini and much faster
speeds it's pretty much four times
faster and now let's talk about battery
life and if the 13 mini has enough
battery life for most people now apple
said that it got an extra hour and a
half of battery life compared to the 12
mini and that battery life is actually
the reason why most people did not buy
the 12 mini this thing didn't last very
long but how's that compared to the
other phones well apple gave us some
different quotes but mr who's the boss
actually did an insane battery test he
had to change his plans for the evening
because of how long it took and he gave
us some really great answers and we have
some big improvements now the se lasted
just about three and a half hours which
is terrible that is terrible battery
life uh he didn't test the 12 but i've
tested it before and in previous tests
it's about five hours of battery life
where the 13 mini gets six and a half
hours of battery life now what is very
interesting is that the 13 mini now
beats out the iphone 12 which most
people were happy with that then got a
little bit less than six hours of screen
on time so if you're somebody that
didn't buy a 12 minute because the
battery life you went with the 12 but
you would like a smaller phone the 13
mini is now better and six and a half
hours is great for most people now of
course if you're trying to compare it to
the iphone 13 that got about 7 hours and
45 minutes so apple coded about an hour
more than the 13 mini in reality it's
actually a little bit better than that
but overall battery life has been fixed
and that is why we see nice speed
improvements here in the 5g speeds i
think apple had to slow down the 12 mini
because of the poor battery life slow
down the reception use less wattage and
that gave you worse reception and worse
speeds where now with the 13 mini apple
doesn't have to do that now along with
that we should also talk about charging
of course all the 12s and 13s support
magsafe so you can attach like this you
can charge with that you can also use
different accessories for example we
have wallets and the cool thing about
wallets is that with a 12-minute or the
13-minute they fit perfectly on the
phone itself so i've done tests where it
really doesn't fall off with the mini
phones compared to the 13 or the 12
whereas there's a lot more room for this
to slide around so that is definitely a
benefit the same thing goes for apple's
little charging pack that they came out
with magsafe that fits perfectly on
those phones as well and of course with
the iphone se we do not have that
capability for magsafe same thing with
older iphones and i will say max safe
has been a game changer i love attaching
my phone to
my little car mount being able to charge
while i'm using gps and having that
convenience charging at home
using different accessories magsafe is
awesome and i think it's well worth
getting a newer phone to have that
capability and the last secret that i
want to cover has to do with charging
now unfortunately if you're using
magsafe apple is still limiting that
charging to 12 watts compared to 15
watts with the regular 13s the 12s the
pro models so you are still limited
because it has that larger battery
compared to last year's 12 mini it will
take even longer to charge but with that
said if you are using wire charging what
a lot of people didn't know is that the
12 mini was also fairly limited in my
test it got about 12 or so watts instead
of the full 20 watts from of those newer
adapters but with the 13 mini it was
running at about 16 and a half watts it
actually peaked at over 17 maybe 17 and
a half watts of charging so if you want
fast charging definitely use a cable and
you will get faster speeds than even the
12 mini when you're charging with the
cable now with that said you actually
don't need to have a 20 watt adapter an
18 watt old one will work just fine to
get the maximum performance so don't
think you have to go buy a new one if
you have an older one now of course we
do recommend going with an anchor
charger they're currently not yet a
sponsor with us but this guy right here
is i think 11 or 12 bucks it also has
folding prongs which are very nice and
apples one doesn't offer that so i'll go
ahead and leave a link to that down in
the video description below and before i
give my final verdict we have to cover
the cameras just like last year the 13
mini has the same exact cameras as the
13 which is an amazing thing but this
year of course the 13s and the 13 mini
have the same cameras from the 12 pro
max so we have that sensor stabilization
we have the ultrawide that's also been
improved so that is awesome and when we
compare it to the 12 mini you guys can
see just how much larger those camera
lenses are now of course the 13s don't
have the three times telephoto that
comes with the 13 pro
but other than that if you guys want to
see how the cameras compare to say the
iphone 12s
or the 12 pro max you guys could
actually go and check out my camera
comparison that's very detailed and if
you're wondering is it really worth the
pro camera to get that extra telephoto
and the other updates such as the larger
sensor i actually have a video that came
out i think that was yesterday posted
you guys can check that out and see if
that telephoto really makes a difference
for you along with the upgraded ultra
wide lens now those videos are available
but let's see how much better is the 13
mini's camera compared to the single
camera that is on the iphone se here's a
regular shot in normal lighting and you
guys can see how much more detail we
have with the new mini and here's a shot
with night mode which of course the sc
does not have it looks so much better
having that capability and then with the
front facing state camera we also have
night mode it makes low light shots look
much better and much more detailed and
then if you're somebody that wants to
zoom without a telephoto here is how the
zoom shot looks with apple's upscaling
and then of course we have the ultra
wide lens which is very helpful and a
lot of different scenarios gives you
really nice angles and then a regular
selfie shot this has actually blur from
the portrait mode that you can get and
the same thing goes with portraits using
that standard lens that capability makes
your photos look a lot more professional
you can blur out background so if you're
somebody that's considering these phones
i would definitely say if you care about
camera quality at all
you have to go with the 13 mini so what
is my final verdict on the iphone 13
mini is it worth upgrading to from an
older iphone in even the iphone 12 mini
and is it worth buying instead of a much
cheaper iphone se and should you spend
more money potentially and get the 13 or
the same amount of money get the 12.
those are a lot of answers uh to give
you guys but i'll straight up say yes it
is worth it if you wanted a smaller
phone last year but you didn't go for it
buy it now if you cared about the
battery life and it wasn't good enough
now it is it even beats out the 12 and
the other features such as the better
processor brighter display and if you
like having a smaller phone i would buy
it instead of the iphone 12. now with
that said
if you have older phones and you kind of
like that smaller size i would still say
go for there's so many more improvements
for the extra money i would definitely
not get the 12 mini 400 less since that
is still for sale you get so many
improvements especially the antennas and
that reception that matters a lot and
much better battery life as well and
then the cameras and then compared to
the 13 well if you're somebody that
watches a lot of videos you listen to
music with the built-in speakers or you
play games having that larger screen
with the better speakers is nice but
outside of that unless you know you need
killer battery life the 13 mini still
delivers it has very little downsides
and you save a hundred dollars and have
a much more smaller compact phone that
just fits so nicely in the hand and then
that mini size with the wallet or the
mac safe power pack that works out
really well so this year i actually am
very happy with the 13 mini and
the last secret actually
is that right now based on all the info
we have apple is not going to be making
another mini phone so if you wanted to
upgrade from an older iphone or from the
12 mini or you just want a small phone
it is worth buying it this year with the
13 mini with that new processor the
better cameras because going into the
future it looks like apple is going to
have a new version of the se a cheaper
one that is not going to be matching up
to their flagship phones it's going to
be lower processor worst cameras so
there will be a lot of other drawbacks
in order to get the smaller size
compared to right now if you're buying a
13 mini it is most of what the 13 offers
for a lower price same performance ram
cameras it is a really nice phone if you
like that smaller size so there you guys
go let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below of course you guys
could pick up one of those chargers for
your phones with the link that's a great
price and click that subscribe button
above if you guys want to help us reach
a million subscribers and see more
videos check out one of those great
camera comparisons right over there this
has been max and i will see you in the
next video
[Music]